[Music]
uh right up top want to get something
out of the way I am no
scholar just feels good to let that out
people always asking you a scholar nope
not a scholar I know my giant head gives
the illusion of a giant
brain but really up here it's mostly
Bible verses and Saved by the Bell
quotes I go and it's just coolly
preppy the meek shall inherit the Earth
all I got
but you know what I hate feeling dumb
because I don't know something people
standing around adults standing around
I'm seeing a lot of vests know I mean
discussing 19th century Russian
literature someone turns to me like
wouldn't you agree that even when dooi
was writing about life he was actually
writing about
death and the spotlights on me and I'm
just
like totally
but that's before I figured something
out if you don't know 19th century
Russian literature or anything you can
fake it just fake it find something you
can say just be like oh yeah I prefer
his early
work clean done you just faked it they
all agree with you laughing their snobby
non-moving jaw laughs he like indeed
huzzah H CAC into the
fire now don't get me wrong there is a
time to admit you don't know something
that's part of being a grown-up in
humility bow your head and admit and
take the opportunity to learn and grow I
call that time most of the time but some
of the time fake it save yourself a
little Hassle and have a little fun it's
just a good time and it works for all
sorts of stuff for example I never want
to admit that I know nothing about cars
because I'm man and I feel like men are
supposed to know like real men you know
men not this hello not
this talking about real men always have
a rag yeah that sort of guy hulking
confident even their resting face looks
angry I'm quite calm
actually so when a real man and I are
driving and my car starts making noises
he's all like what do you think it is
Pete
carburetor fuel injector I'm pulling it
over like I don't
know
demons I don't like that feeling he
knows I'm full of so now I fake it
if my car makes a squeaky noise or loud
pangs oils leaking out the back like Spy
Hunter I don't know what's wrong but I
fake it I just go look at
that fan belts acting up
again listen to me carefully I'm 35 I
figured this out always go with fan belt
fan belt it works it makes you sound
like you know what you're talking about
and listen to this there's a good chance
it actually is the fan
Bel i f it at parties too you know at a
party you're stuck talking to a bunch of
intellectuals you just want to fit in
you're feeling out of your depth just
wait for a lull and go oh yeah yeah but
my
passion
documentaries
you're in you just jumped three notches
up on the genius stick they have no idea
the last documentary I saw was Katy
Perry Part of
Me doesn't matter I'm Mar in the clear
you see uh she kissed a girl but she in
fact is herself a girl so it's truly a
song about loving
oneself and her titties are
[Applause]
cupcakes not even done this is a helpful
ass monologue I swear to God here's
another great faking at buzzword to
sound smart exhibit not the
rapper trust me you're not going to win
any intellectual Friends by being like I
love the way he's always pimping things
it's
not talking about exhibits like Museum
exhibits you want to impress some dork
valadi dictorian and a stuffy Blazer
that smells like the upper stacks of a
forgotten government
Library just look him dead in the eye
and be like last weekend I saw the most
delightful
exhibit suddenly his bone dry salivary
glands kick into overdrive he's like
oh ex
exhibit that's a diarama you can get
inside Bo brain boners for everybody
it's
faking another area that always
intimidates me in conversation politics
I'm way out of my depth as soon as I
hear words like Congress filibuster veto
which is my favorite political term by
the the way I know what it means but
whenever I hear it I picture the
president sending in like a husky
Italian man
to to overturn a law just like President
says he doesn't like this one
oh so here's how I fake my way through
any political conversation I just let
the other person talk and I
nod a lot this reads to my peers as
contemplative meanwhile in my brain it's
just like an overweight
Geral running on a wheel trying to catch
that one pellet of food one day that's
all that's happening up
here then it's my turn to talk all this
politics stuff has been happening I want
to fit in I wait for a l and I just go
Obamacare that's it that's the essence
of Faking it and you got to say it in a
way where you can't tell if you're four
or against
Obamacare because to be honest I have no
idea what Obamacare is even is even
though I think I need
it but as far as I can tell it's health
care that's either free or costs more or
works or doesn't work I can't be sure
but I do know it's politics cuz the
president's name is in
[Applause]
[Music]
it